we've got the las vegas reopening
symphony orchestra back up and running
because
a fresh new hotel is now open in las
vegas they just took the tags off the
thing
virgin hotels replaces the old hard rock
hotel of course and the doors open last
night hector mejia is live outside with
a look at the outside and the inside
hector good morning to you sir
good morning and this property is just
about 12
hours old so it's just a baby and the
newest property in town obviously opened
up
with a fabulous las vegas party in case
you haven't seen it check out the main
entrance here to the virgin hotels las
vegas
this new uh this renovated building here
operating
and uh looking like a modern desert
oasis that's what it's uh
described as the opening party was
electric it was fun it was wild with new
restaurants and bars we even saw people
on stilts
as guests marveled at the new amenities
for the first time ever
just last year it was the famous hard
rock hotel
two hundred million dollars in
renovations updated everything including
fifteen hundred rooms
it's providing sixteen hundred jobs this
week
the goal is to hire four hundred more
when renovations reach
a hundred this percent something special
as this city comes back
and leads the way of people starting to
travel and enjoy experiences again
now seeing vegas open and people
investing in new hotels like this is
symbolic to say
we're not out of the woods yet but we're
over the worst
and also the mohegan sun casino here at
the virgin property is the first casino
operated by a native american tribe here
in las vegas so that's a first
and the only parts of the property that
are not open yet
are the pool and the date club those are
set to open
in may reporting live this morning
hector mejia john
back to you